good afternoon
welcome to our press room for the weekly
college
readout and a subsequent
press conference before moving on to the
press conference with commissioner
celekides on the european health union
proposals adopted today
by the college let me briefly take you
through the other points discussed
during today's college meeting
first the colleague college sorry
authorized a fourth
contract with pharmaceutical company
biontec
pfizer it covers the purchase of up to
300 million
doses to be supplied once the vaccine
has proven to be safe
and effective against covid19
the commission has been working on
building a diversified portfolio of
potential vaccines
based on different technologies which
will ensure
that europe is well prepared for
vaccination against
again once the vaccines have proven to
be safe
and effective then the college
discussed the lgbtiq equality strategy
the first ever eu strategy in this area
as announced by president van der laan
in her 2020
state of the union address vice
president jorova
and commissioner dali will present the
strategy to you
in a press conference here tomorrow
commissioners also discuss the new
agenda for consumers
which will further protect european
consumers with the time horizon
2025 and vice president eurovision
commissioner heindez
will present the agenda in a press
conference on friday
finally let me mention one item related
to human
resources today the college decided to
appoint mrs
bertie grinder as a deputy director
general
in charge of the task force migration
management
in the director general migration and
home affairs
as part of the new pact on migration
asylum the task force coordinates
the union's work on all strategic legal
operational and financial issues related
to migration
management and with this i passed the
floor to commissioner akira yakidas
on the health package adopted
thank today very much good morning
everyone
first of all may i thank you for being
here
and say that i would have been here also
with vice president
margaret and i want to thank
him and his of course his team for the
contribution to what we are announcing
today
and i hope and i'm sure he'll be with us
shortly in this press room so
ladies and gentlemen the past year
has taught us how crucially important
health is for each
and every one of us it has shown us how
fragile our societies are
and how fast everything can be turned
upside
down by something so small
that is invisible to the naked eye
it has taught us that health is a
precondition
of our societies and economies to
function
and it has reminded us of the value of
solidarity and cooperation
and being united in diversity to
overcome the biggest health crisis
in modern times the health
of one member state the health situation
in one member state
is contingent on that of others
to minimize the negative impacts on
people and business
we have to work together to address
health threats
the past year has shown us that
fragmentation makes
all member states vulnerable
we all witness the effects of the
uncoordinated
national measures during the first weeks
and
even months of the outbreak we also saw
the lack of readiness and preparation
with shortfalls in medical equipment
testing capacity
and coordination and other areas
in times of crisis where we are faced
with health threats
that transcend national borders
citizens expect the eu
to take a more active role in protecting
them
2020 will forever be remembered as the
year
of the worst global health crisis in
modern times
broke out but i would also like it to be
remembered
as the year where we listened and lived
up to the citizens demands
for more europe in the area of public
health
and this is why today we are proposing
to put in place the first building
blocks
of a more secure a better prepared
and the more resilient eu in the area of
health
our eu vaccine strategy has already
shown what we can do
what we can achieve when we're working
together
the agreement we have approved with
biotech pfizer today
is our fourth contract so far and the
step
closer to what we set out to do
to have a broad and solid vaccine
portfolio
we have been building up on for the last
months
and whilst we are continuing to work 24
7 in our response to the immediate
crisis
we also need to learn from the lessons
over the past year
and we need to make sure that we are
better prepared for the future
today is an important day
it is an important day for the vision
that we have
for the health of the european citizens
with today's proposals we are taking the
first steps
towards a european health union giving
us stronger legislation to act
and support member states in situations
of serious
cross-border threats to health
we are also going to make sure that our
two eu agencies
who have been at the forefront of our
work the european center for disease
prevention and control
ecdc and the european medicines agency
emma have the necessary capacity to
fully play the role we need them to
this is going to be a step change for
eu's collective capacity
to respond and to coordinate
with today's proposals our response will
in the future be stronger and
importantly also more coherent
it will be stronger because we will be
able to together with ecdc
formally adopt recommendations on what
response measures to take
it will be more coherent because our
measures will be based on the same
scientific basis
this will avoid the confusion that
citizens can feel
when they are faced with fundamentally
different
measures in place we will now also be
able to declare an emergency situation
together
at eu level and activate our emergency
response mechanisms
for example in order to stockpile in
order to procure the necessary equipment
we will set up an eu health task force
within the ecdc that can be mobilized
and deployed quickly to member states
but also to third countries in cases of
outbreaks of communicable diseases
with today's proposals we will be better
prepared
we will be better prepared because we
will develop eu
and national crisis preparedness
response plans
that will regularly stress and audit
we'll make sure that stockpiles and
equipment are not only there on paper
but also in reality we will train
medical staff to give them the right
skills for health emergency
and preparedness so that everyone
everyone who falls sick can be properly
cared for
and we will be working with member
states on common indicators
and data that gives us a precise picture
of the state of readiness
and capacity of health systems so
shortages can be mitigated
early and treatments made available to
patients
unfortunately we live in a time where
infectious diseases may emerge at any
point
we all need to be ready for the next
pandemic
or the next health emergency our
proposals will also ensure that we can
better anticipate health risks
ecdc will be able to develop
state-of-the-art systems
to monitor emerging diseases and other
health threats
and provide evidence for improved risk
assessment
rapid reel action and informed decisions
now when it comes to the european
medicines agency emma
we will empower it to closely track
potential shortages of medicines and
medical devices
both in view avoiding future crisis and
once a crisis
is declared no one
no one in the eu should be left without
the necessary treatment
emma will also have a great role in
coordinated clinical trials and vaccine
research
crucial in a crisis situation where
speed is of essence
and finally in the event of a health
emergency
we need to rapidly deploy the most
advanced measures
whether medical or other we need to know
the biomedical innovations
that are crisis relevant and we need to
have the
capacity to develop and procure and stop
the necessary
items this is why we'll be proposing
an eu health emergency preparedness and
response authority
this can be a game-changing initiative
for us
our strategic preparedness our ability
to anticipate threats
and to strengthen our common response in
the eu
you will hear us call it hera
these measures will increase our
resilience to cross-border health
threats
starting with the covet-19 crisis
ladies and gentlemen i said that this is
an important day
this is an important day for all of us
for citizens for the european parliament
for member states for the commission
the european health union is about
preparing for
and facing up to common health threats
together as a union
it is also about building strong eu
health systems overall
that can deliver better outcomes for eu
citizens in their daily lives
but our health union can only be as
strong
as the commitment of our member states
i therefore call on them all and of
course the european parliament
to join us in what must be a common
effort
today we are laying the foundations
more building blocks will follow in the
coming weeks
our pharmaceutical strategy and soon
after europe's beating cancer plan
but we will move forward because what we
all want to do
together is meet citizens expectations
in a public health crisis thank you
thank you very much commissioner we will
now move to the
q a uh session let me remind you that
today
we have interpretation into french
german english italian
spanish greek and international
sign language and i would please ask you
to identify yourself before
asking your question and i passed the
floor
to atanasius
thanks very much uh commissioner uh you
mentioned the uh
signature for the contract with uh
pfizer on the uh
potential vaccine could you please give
us a timeline
on when the member states are finally
going to get
sets a vaccine what quantity
could that be for let's say it's country
and
how soon could we expect if you have
relevant info how soon could you
expect the other companies with
whom we have contracts to produce
similar results and since and that's the
second question since
we're now six months or more into this
crisis
how do you judge the uh the conversion
the evolution of the uh
uh of the people's attitude towards
hygiene and health related issues
evolving in these six months we started
in a very
you know difficult situation back in the
early spring late winter of
of 2020 how are we now
on attitude and people's reactions in
hygiene
and habits and all that that are very
crucial for
uh the pandemic and its containment
thank you
that those those questions i will say
because there are a number of questions
first of all um the the recent
announcements by
pfizer bayern tech were of course
extremely important and we're looking at
it
closely in terms of the question of when
do we expect this vaccines to be
available or other vaccines
i have avoided and i will not do now
going to
discussing specific timelines or
scenarios
as we all understand there is a process
we await
now for the next results that pfizer
biontech will announce
and of course for any vaccine to
be available within the european union
it has to receive
european authorization from the european
medicines agency
so there's a number of steps that need
to be followed
before we are able to actually
have a timeline of when a
success when a vaccine will be available
but i will say this
and i think that this needs to be the
clear message that from day one the
european commission
has moved very quickly and left no stone
unturned
because we know how important it is to
find a safe and effective vaccine
as a way out of this pandemic and so
there will be no delay
once uh bayern tech pfizer
or other companies submit for
authorization to the european medicines
agency
um there needs to be this scientific
assessment in order of safety but we
will be there will be no delay
the second point i want to raise in
relation to
to this and it ties in with your second
question
is that i also am fully aware
of the expectations of citizens for this
vaccine
we need to understand that even when we
have a safe and effective vaccine
this will not be a silver bullet that
will change
and make covet 19 disappear overnight
we need to be aware and i fully
understand the pandemic fatigue that
we're seeing
and you you mentioned
it is extremely difficult for citizens
for all of us
to live with this huge disruption in our
daily lives are the way we
um our social lives our working lives
our family lives
everything has been disrupted but we are
going to need to be able to have
clear communication messages to citizens
that even when a safe and effective
vaccine is there and available
there will be need to go continue with
these measures
until we are able to reach a significant
part of the population
so uh hope is there
but i also want to make sure that we
send the right messages
to everyone that we need to continue to
take the measures that have been put
into place this is extremely important
to protect ourselves and those more
vulnerable around us
thank you thank you very much
um we now move to david carretta
thank you very much david carretta radio
radical italian radio um
two two topics if i may the first one
on on the
health european union
why should member states do what they
hasn't done until
now in terms of coordination
more standard on data and so on
if you if we look back to what happened
since
since april we have had some improvement
but still uh there are member states
that are not so keen to cooperate at eu
level
the second question is uh related and
it's on on vaccines
i'd like to know uh how many countries
has presented until now their national
vaccination plans
if italy is among them
and if you are going to perform
the first review in november as you
announced in
in in october and are you going to
deploy
uh vaccines to a member states
that has not the proper capacity
to perform vaccination
because i'm wondering if it's worth to
send
millions of doses if these doses cannot
be
inoculated to people in member states
thank you
there are two questions i'll take them
in the order that you have submitted it
for the first one
why should member states follow
what we are now recommending under the
european health union
i think in many ways we have come a very
long way since the beginning of this
pandemic
unfortunately at the cost
of thousands of lives of our citizens
and at the huge
turmoil of of our economies
but i believe that we have also come a
long way in understanding the importance
of what we can all do together and how
important solidarity is
and this is why i
am optimistic that member states
will be looking at this step as a step
forward in the right direction
because today's proposals
will be translating into concrete
advantages for their citizens
when it is implemented um
let us take an example we're going to be
able to have
eu outbreak response teams to assist
them
when they do have a public health crisis
or we're going to be able to facilitate
in the development
of potential treatments of vaccines when
they are available
i'm not going to go into the many
details included in the
european union health package but i
believe that we are not
now where we were in terms of
the way we were working together as a
union
um in uh january and february and the
best
possible example of that i would say is
the euro
is the european union vaccine strategy
when we've been working for the last
five or six months together with 27
member states and we've secured
four contracts and are already
completing negotiations on another two
so i think that we all know that our
strength comes out of our solidarity
the second question is
on the vaccination national cancer
national plans the covet vaccination
strategies
as you know we reached out to member
states already because they need to have
an infrastructure the logistics
sometimes are quite complicated we
reached out to them in october
i followed this up with a letter to all
the eu health ministers last wednesday
we'll be again towards the end of this
month with
looking at to see with each member state
what they have in place
and contacting them to see for their
national
national plans and then we will have
be able to have the feedback and prepare
a report on
this so we're monitoring this extremely
closely
thank you thank you i know
thank you i now pass the floor to louise
with
hello commissioner thank you for this
briefing um
i have a question on the risk of
coronavirus mutations because as you
probably know
it detects a new mutation has been
detected in denmark the so-called
cluster fine
and the danish government has decided to
call all the mink
every mink and every mink farm so do you
think this is the right decision and
would you recommend for other countries
to also
call all the mink not only the infected
ones thank you
we seem to have a slight issue with the
sound
okay is it okay yeah go ahead thank you
we're very aware of the situation um of
the mink farms in denmark
it's a situation that is a commission
and with ecdc we're following very
carefully
i would also say that
infection in minks has been reported in
other member states and in other third
countries
of course the measures taken in denmark
are national competence but i would like
to
tell you that uh we are expecting a risk
assessment from ecdc
uh in the coming days uh so we'll be
able to have more uh
more details on that but we're following
the situation uh extremely closely
thank you
should have taken longer yes apologies
for that we had a slight
technical issue that we needed to to
solve
okay we now move on to the next question
from christian spielman which i believe
will be in french
christian
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you so much a number of questions
there
um you're absolutely right
absolutely right that we need to look at
our communication
and we need to look at it early to
address vaccine
hesitancy vaccine vaccine hesitancy has
been
around for a long time before the
discussion of the kobit-19 vaccines
but definitely something that we need to
address and to communicate to citizens
now
and one issue that um we need to be
aware of
is to raise a an understanding of
uh the reason because a lot i hear a lot
of people saying that
this vaccine is not going to be safe
because it's coming in so quickly but
the reasons
that it's being developed so quickly is
because we're investing as a commission
and globally the world
of of science is investing a great deal
in it of course
but also because technology allows us to
move much faster so
being um coming in a shorter time span
than usually vaccines would will not
make them less safe because in order for
them to be authorized they need to go
through the european medicines
agency so the issue of safety is
paramount
to gain citizens trust in vaccines
and i think that this is extremely
important for us
and we're already working with the
member states in terms of these
communication strategies with them
the second question is
concerning the
the groups that will be vaccinated first
this is um we put it out in
october together with ecdc in our
vaccination strategy
the healthcare workers the more
vulnerable
those in older groups but this is of
course up to national
uh specific specificities so
uh we're working with the member states
and with ecdc
to put forward um our guidelines for
this but then it will be
up to the national specific
specificities in each member state
to decide how they move forward um
i think what was the third question
oh why did it take so long not for to
move forward
i always say out of crisis come
opportunities
and um it's the first time that we have
been faced with this unprecedented
public health crisis
and for myself the question isn't so
much why did it take so long
but for myself the importance
importance is that we're standing here
today and while dealing with the
pandemic 24 7
we are listening and we've taken action
and we're putting forward the
foundations for the european health
union
so the fact that we're acting now i
think speaks for itself on how much we
have been
listening to the concerns of citizens
for the last 10 months
thank you thank you we now move
to jillian
hi thank you eric and this is julian
dewitt with politico thank you
commissioner kirikatis for hosting this
as well
i have two main questions for you um
first you know we've seen
capitals struggle to even harmonize
their quarantine and testing roles
so i'm wondering you know how realistic
some of these proposals are
especially considering the last european
council summit or video conference on
the dutch prime minister
mark ruta said that in fighting the
epidemiological and biological crisis
europe has no additional value i'm
curious how you can
plan to convince him otherwise my second
question is that you know obviously this
is a very important day for brussels
um but we're still in the middle of a
second wave and i'm curious if there are
things
right now that capitals can do to
transfer some of this power
um two brussels now and let let brussels
voluntarily take the lead
thank you
all right thank you julian uh for those
two questions so for the first question
yes in terms of quarantine levels there
are
there is a we have managed to reach an
agreement on
on them at the beginning of of september
this is still being discussed now
together with ecdc
it is not always easy to get this
this consensus but i am convinced that
uh
slowly um despite the fact that there
are wide
different measures across member states
we are able to to work
together after tasking ecdc to look at
it and we're expecting them
to come forward with a proposal in the
coming weeks
second question was on
rick remind me
the value
and and i think that julian asks
actually said that we're in the middle
of a pandemic and how will this actually
impact well we're not taking our eyes
off this pandemic when proposing the
european health union
but the value of eu action in the last
month
speaks for itself and i can
say that with a certain amount i would
say of
of confidence because we have seen how
member states have worked together uh to
align and to work together
for testing strategies for
now we're working together for rapid
tests how we form the green lanes
in order to allow freedom of movement of
essential goods
how we work together for guidelines for
travel and and tourism so
a lot there is a lot out there which
shows solidarity uh
and i think that this um this next step
that we're
we're proposing puts down the
foundations
so that these are safeguarded in the
future
and not only that so that we can foresee
and predict
crisis before they happen because part
of
being effective in a crisis is to be
able to predict and foresee
and not only to react so this i think is
a very important part
of the european uh health union package
that we're putting forward today
thank you thank you we now move to
mariapsar
hello i hope you can hear me yes go
ahead
okay uh marietta with open tv greece
two questions if i may the first today
the health issue remains a national
competence what exactly your new
proposal will change
in practical terms it is a follow-up
question will you be ready to impose
same mandatory measures in different
european countries
and the second question how many
countries have sent already their
vaccination plans and if greece and
cyprus
are between them thank you very much
the second question i will leave up to
the technical briefing afterwards
because i don't have that information
the first question first of all let me
say maria and thank you for the
questions whatever we're proposing today
in terms of the health union package
is well within our competence
in relation to the treaty we member
states
have the responsibility for their their
health systems
but we are also able to propose
the health union package respecting the
treaty and this needs to be clear
what will member states and citizens
gain i think we need to speak about
citizens
and see some of the concrete advantages
there are a number of concrete
advantages that
citizens across the eu will gain i've
mentioned some of them
but for example tackling shortages of
medicines and medical devices being able
to see
where there are going to be these
shortages before they happen
monitoring the health system indicators
so we will know member states what the
hospital and icu capacity is making sure
that treatments are there and they're
available for patients
sending a health task force to member
states when there are health threats
this in itself is is going to be
extremely important
providing medical staff with the right
skills uh i could go on listing what
this will mean
in practice and i believe that
once we once we look at it uh
at the level individual level of member
states we will see that there is a lot
of value
in the hell in moving together as a
health union and the strength really of
our solidarity
so stronger agencies
will mean more coordinated
and the reaction in real time as well
thank you
thank you we moved now to the deutsches
item
thank you commissioner for this briefing
thank you for taking my question i've
switched off my camera because i have
low bandwidth i think it's going to be a
struggle wise
um i have two questions one is on the
timeline of your proposals
i guess those proposals will need some
discussions especially amongst member
states in the council
so i'm curious and would you hope to
see these proposals uh implement and
come into force
or more generally do you think there
will be value for this ongoing pandemic
or is this
going to be for for the next pandemic
which might come away the second is
again on the bayern tech fighter
contracts i'm curious um this company
and maybe
some of the others too have already um
contracts with other areas of the world
the united states the united kingdom
and i'm wondering could tell us
something about the order in which these
contracts are going to be fulfilled
is it on the first you know first come
first
um uh yeah like is it like who has the
first contract
to be served first or is there another
provision for that thank you very much
um thank you carolina for your question
on the on the first question
i will just tell you that we're going to
be moving
as soon as possible the presidencies
have
committed to move forward as soon as
possible and
the european parliament is a is also
going to be moving on this immediately
[Music]
i would also uh say that some of what we
have in the european health union
package were already
uh doing now in terms of
of our reaction to the pandemic and
working with pandemic so
putting this forward and i want to
stress this does not mean that we are
taking our eyes off
every single day of what we need to be
doing to address the current situation
on the on the second question
each contract has its own timeline
whichever company applies for
authorized market authorization first
will be examined by
emma but it won't be if i understood
the first come first serve basis was in
terms of the member states
and not only of the companies no this is
part of the element of solidarity in the
vaccine strategy that all member states
will have access to the vaccines
once approved at the same time thank you
the other regions of the world
if it goes to the us
and well no we we in our vaccine
strategy we don't have
uh uh any information that it will be
going first
to to any other parts of the world
before so we are
closing our our contracts for access of
the vaccines to the european union
thank you we now move to catalin
hello good good afternoon can you hear
me yes go ahead yes
thank you very much
[Music]
there are some concerns
by biologists
because of the pfizer biotech coveted
vaccine
whether there are
there was enough time for the follow-up
time for
vaccine-related side effects is too
short
they say and um it is not clear
that the vaccination is equally
effective in different groups
especially in risk groups such as the
elderly
and it's uh also not clear enough
whether
how long does the vaccination protection
lead so this is the
safety issues and on
greater scale whether there are specific
plans for the proportion to be
distributed among the eu member states
who can enjoy priority the member states
who
suffer the most or according
age groups member states who have
the most elderly people so what are the
plans
thank you very much
yes thank you um
first of all like i'm not here i cannot
really comment on what
some scientists are saying what i can
tell you is this
i can fully respect the concerns
that we hear especially in the
relation to vaccine related
possible side effects so the length of
the duration of the vaccine
but this is all clinical data and
scientific data that will be addressed
by the european medicines agency
once application for market
authorization is submitted
and the european medicines agency of
course will be taking everything
into consideration before um
proceeding with approval of a vaccine
the second question
in terms of which member states priority
and the distribution there will be um a
pro-rata distribution according to
population size this is what has been
agreed and the member states will be
deciding on their national um
on how they will distribute this
nationally
and their and the groups that they will
vaccinate first and we have discussed
this
with them throughout the vaccination
strategy thank you
thank you um there are many many
questions we will not be able to take
them all
yes uh during the press conference so
we'll take two last questions and then
we will move on to the technical
briefing
i now move to fabio fabio napoli
good oh yes good morning i'm
fabionna i'm a fabio napoli
from italian press agency policy
europe i have two questions
first is about money
how much money we needed
in order to reinforce the
two agency
and the
there are some obligations for
pharmaceutical companies in this
in these two new proposals
thank you
i'll answer the first question i'm not
sure i understood the second one
um fabioso um thank you for your
questions
how much will it cost and who pays for
it um
i can give you some some initial figures
uh what we have to do with we are
proposing is to
strengthen ecdc with um
about 73 additional staff members
40 for the european medicines agency and
21 for dg
santa which of course coordinates the
overall crisis framework in our health
area
this is an amount of what we estimate
about 605 million
euro for the next seven years
so to finance the two agencies
and the eu action in this field so this
is less
than 100 million approximately a year
these are figures that we're going to be
coming back to
so even with this increase i would say
that it's a very small
amount of increase to the eu budget of
the agencies
and we're really investing on our future
we're investing on the future of
the cities of the health of the european
union citizens
and i'm very encouraged i'll share this
with you that the eu
for health program is emerging even
stronger
after yesterday's political agreement
we need to wait to see the detailed
outcome of course of the discussions
but i believe that we all understand
parliament member states and we
definitely do that
we need to invest in the european
uh health union this is the only way
forward to
be able to face up to future crisis and
deal with the current one as well
all right last question i don't
understand the second question
yes but i think we will move over to the
last question today for tomaso
yes thank you good good afternoon
commissioner thank you for taking my
questions
uh two quick questions if i may the
first one is on timing i understand you
don't want to elaborate too much
on timing but i heard you this morning
on euron user
saying that in the fact the first doses
of the vaccine
might come in in towards the end of 2020
and the beginning of 2021
would you please at least confirm this
timing and the second one is on the call
chain
which is a critical aspect for
distribution do you think the member
states are
ready or will be ready to deploy the
necessary call chain to distribute the
fight sir biontech vaccine thank you
so thank you so much uh yes i have said
that towards the end of 2020
end of 2021 which is
early 2021 end of 2020 early 2021
is is possibly what we would see as a
as a positive scenario but you have seen
the whole world
is looking at how clinical trials
develop i think this is the first time
the whole world is looking at a
development of clinical trials you can
have twists and turns in this process
so i try and avoid putting deadlines but
this is a scenario
that that is a positive scenario
that one could look at but
i wouldn't put any more deadlines
until we have more information and see
when we also have submission for
authorization
and the second question is the logistics
i think i've answered that
we know this is going to be a
challenging operation and
challenging for member states that's why
we worked
as a commission from very early on from
october with member states
and we're not taking our eyes off this
it's important for us
to ensure that we support and help
member states and make sure that they
are prepared
so when this effective and safe vaccine
or vaccines are available they can reach
citizens as quickly as possible
for us this is um a priority
and we're not going to take our eyes of
it thank you
thank you very much this brings us to
the end of our press conference which
will now be followed by a technical
briefing
and i understand and i apologize for
that that there were some
sound issues at the beginning but you
can of course
find the college readout on ebs
the clip will be of course uploaded on
our audiovisual website so
you can find my opening remarks and the
beginning of the commissioner's
intervention
on ebs in in any case thank you very
much stay connected
for the technical briefing
you